I feel like the name vada Pao is exactly
how I feel when I tell you buy it
[Music]
I've had Indian food before but never
street food I don't really know what to
expect with street foods when I go to a
restaurant there are a lot of sauces
maybe it'll be something that you can
like hold and walk with easier than a
curry there's probably gonna be spice in
it I'm expecting that Street food is
usually fast casual spicy yeah I'm not
sure what to expect and I think that's
part of the the curiosity of it all is
that what would be the difference oh yes
looks so good fine already great there's
like some red spice creamy potatoes on
the inside a nice hard crispy fry on the
outside the sauce is kind of sweet which
makes it really nice it's like an
upgraded hash brown it's so good Wow
it's a Big Mac I think this is one of
the best things I've ever put in my
mouth I'm not [ __ ] you
this is unbeatable whose spiced but a
sweetness and then a kick from onion
like this was very well thought out
flavor-wise this is spicy for me like my
mouth is on fire right now but I want to
keep eating it oh good you feel is there
mmm it's just such an insult because
it's like for a McDonald's burger to be
like 2 bucks and this is like 60 cents
in India like get out cuz the McDonald's
burger does even have like half of
flavor you know what they should have
this for sale outside every bar in LA in
the world
this already looks like something a
health food store could sell for $15
there's a lot going on in here yeah it's
like puffed rice yeah Oh cold
I expect to be hot it's very sweet but
it's like sweet but refreshing at the
same time eat fight is just a
kaleidoscope of flavors it's like a
fried rice potato salad it does remind
me of like a fancy salad right yeah it's
got this sweet tamarind flavor of I'm
not expecting it was I mean it was great
because it was they were all things I'd
never tried before and it gave me a
newfound respect for vegetarian food I
mean this was all these all didn't have
mean in it and they were delicious
I don't know I was expecting cones stuff
doesn't make any sense I suspect you
like curry on a cone I don't know I feel
like I'm just wrapped up in a bunch of
blankets and there's puppies giving me
kisses
oh great drunk food I am so happy
best tasters ever I really want to try
Indian Street desserts comment below